I just realized you hadn't told the
people what you do oh yeah
most people know you but I mean yeah
just for you know discrepancy uh yeah
and I'm sung one show I go by Pro ZD
online uh I do YouTube I'm a voice actor
it's kind of uh right you're
underselling yourself yeah he's voiced
in so many cool [ __ ] he you blew up on
Vine right yeah yeah and then you've
killed it and you also have the world
record for getting banned on Tick Tock
what happened there what was that I have
no idea I was on it for about a week uh
and then uh I just woke like my wife
texted me because I was out of town and
she's like why are you banned on Tick
Tock I was like what do you mean why am
I being a tick tock and I was banned on
Tick Tock and so I think I scared them
off with the tweet in the video that I
made right whereas I don't care if I'm
unbanned but this is [ __ ] dumb and
yeah
immediately after that I was unmet with
no explanation as to why was it people
were uploading a lot of your content to
tick tock that would have been happening
for years before uh so I don't know if
it was like people flagging me or
because I think because you could swear
on Tick Tock right yeah yeah like I
don't think there's like restrictions on
that so it might have just been like
flagging or something or maybe they
really I mean at the time it wouldn't
let me upload a profile picture yeah so
maybe they thought I was a really
convincing fake or something but back
now I guess yeah so oh my God four
YouTubers try to figure out Tick Tock
yeah right have you used that [ __ ]
app
every now and then yeah every now and
again it's a nightmare yeah it feels
weird because like I use I use YouTube
shorts way more often because at least
like it's I know what my tastes are and
it's like garnered towards my taste Tick
Tock it's like it's a bit scary to put
that much of yourself into just this
[ __ ] algorithm to be like okay I'm
gonna I'm just you are going to let a
computer figure out your entire life
personality by swiping yeah that's
that's basically Tick Tock right yeah
it's like it's like impressive how good
the algorithm is but it's also like
scary too very scary yeah yeah so I mean
we post like clips of like our podcast
and everything on Tick Tock but aside
from that we don't make original content
for tick tock yeah
are you uh do you browse it pretty often
or you know
uh
uh I think for me it was something where
I wanted something that I could just
have no pressure with yeah
um although everything I do with [ __ ]
online I don't do well and I just do it
I just do [ __ ] so it's like but I
guess with at least with YouTube uh I
have to like have some semblance of like
okay I cannot just do board game reviews
and nobody gives a [ __ ] about I have to
like sometimes do a video that maybe
other people will watch so it's like a
balancing act for me right right uh okay
one for me one for them like you know
make sure to make sure that YouTuber
chocolate about it like yeah yeah and
make sure the production values look
like they're from 2007 like that's why
that's my channel like I don't I look at
all this equipment I'm like wow this is
what real YouTubers do I don't know
anything uh I no you know I use my
iPhone to record my videos I I I I got I
had a feeling like but that's part of
the child
no there's definitely demographic that
misses like the old school YouTube Vibe
and style where it's just filmed yeah
see that's not a cut that's not like me
being like this is a smart decision it's
like I'm very lazy yeah
very very lazy uh that's the easiest way
to do it and then that's it
um so going back to tick tock uh yeah I
think it was just like another Avenue of
like
I I don't care how well Tick Tock does
yeah like at all I have no Stakes like
if it does well that's great if not I
don't care because I you know I'm just
brand new on it right yeah so I mean
it's been like pretty pretty good like
like it's but for me what's important is
that I'm having fun with it you know
it's something where I'm actually
inspired now okay I can just put out
like a fun silly little 20-second video
and not have to worry about oh is it
like up to the standards of yeah
whatever blah blah so that's basically
what I've been doing yeah I mean like
your content seems to be like very you
know if I would have to say it would see
it would seem like it would be suited
for tick tock because like very short
form like short form high intensity like
skits and content like that and like I
still plan on doing skits for the
channels specifically yeah
um because I also cannot stand that you
have to film it vertically like I'm so
old like I'm just like I gotta film it
like I'm oh it's gross even Vine was
like a box at least
[ __ ] anyway so I I'm still planning
to do skits and also editing on
Tick Tock is such a nightmare I know I
know you can upload stuff to it yeah I'm
lazy all right again super lazy so it's
like okay if I can just do it in the air
I'll just do it and post it or whatever
yeah that's like the purpose of tick
tock stuff but then for regular skits
it's like okay I'll actually edit it
myself and yeah you know make it a
little nicer
um yeah whereas for if I just have a
silly little idea I can just do it in
like 20 seconds like I just post it up
there and yeah have fun with it right
because like I remember you saying
you're still recording your phone and
everything yeah you never really have
like tried to like Market yourself or
you know make that kind of content but
like I remember when you switched over
to one to YouTube you kind of started
making these skits where it was just
like very short skits but the thumbnail
was just like your face and the title
was just like uh exactly what it says on
the tin kind of like titling and I
remember that was like so unique at the
time for YouTube because everything was
like getting like pristine and proper
with like our marketing and you came
along and it was just like it's just a
guy with like his face and then somehow
that just became the meta everyone's
started doing that lowercase titles yeah
lowercase okay so notice that lowercase
titles do you know I might have told you
this but do you know why those
thumbnails are the way they are why why
you know since the channel has since
I've had that channel like since 2006
it's like
you know how it generates three random
thumbnails yeah I just picked the one I
like best I have never made a single
custom thumbnail video damn at this
point yeah your your producer was like
are you stupid I'm like yeah I'm stupid
and lazy like for me
I when I was younger I always thought it
was fun because back then you couldn't
make a thumbnail yeah yeah I was like
it's funny oh like which one am I going
to use and which one is you know the
best one yeah and for God how long has
it been now like 15 years right I've
never I've never I've never made a
customer I see what the three thumbnails
are right and I picked the one that
looks the most well but sometimes with
those three auto-generated thumbnails
like there are some videos where I've
uploaded where it's just like wow these
all look horrible right it doesn't
matter
so I I was trying to reoplate and like
reshuffle it yeah yeah yeah hold some
other fun man no dude I'm just like okay
uh I I uh had YouTube gave me like a
manager once yeah you guys have a
manager yeah YouTube yeah it's [ __ ]
anyway
so they like were like oh yeah you're
here as a manager and I'm like okay and
he didn't understand me at all he was
like he he pulled up like a video he's
like so what's going on in the thumbnail
I'm like
I don't know
what the [ __ ] yeah because it's like one
of the board game reviews which like you
know I will say the board game reviews
are entirely for me because for those of
you aren't aware I'm a huge Board Game
Fan yeah yeah
um and like people are like you know
these videos are only getting like this
many views I'm like yeah no [ __ ] like
I'm not an idiot I know how numbers work
but for me it's like I just you know
enjoy making them and they're just like
a little side project yeah yeah he was
like looking on them it's just like a
board game on a table maybe my hand is
like a covering half of it because it's
one of the [ __ ] thumbnails he's like
he's like what's going what you know you
can make custom thumbnails I was like I
don't do that he's like he's like he's
like what what do you mean you don't do
I'm like no I don't want to do that it's
like I would recommend I was like I'm
not gonna and then like and then maybe
like a couple months later they're like
okay you're not on you don't have a
partner
they were like this guy doesn't it's
like I'm done I give up this it's like
there's this whole PowerPoint
presentation he was like you know these
videos is like a skit do really well and
these videos board game review don't do
well and I'm like I know
um it's like did you know if you do more
videos like this I'm like okay oh really
thank you so much so you are really very
very
useful
um so for me it's been like
I've been very stubborn because uh
YouTube was like an accident right right
for me it's always been voice I'm very
very passionate about voice acting very
serious about it you know take that very
seriously with YouTube I don't take it
seriously at all and it's managed to
work out like I know it won't last
forever and I know that you know but
even I mean I don't know like it's still
working you know yeah yeah like exactly
so I think for me it's always been like
instead of uh going down a path where I
hate what I'm doing or I'm not at least
enjoying what I'm doing it's like I'll
just
stop doing I'm just gonna do it until
like literally no one gives a [ __ ] and
then hopefully by then I'll be doing
other things yeah yeah I mean like was
it voice acting always like the final
end goal for you oh yeah yeah that was
since um like high school right yeah
High School like that was like my dream
right like to one day maybe be able to
do it yeah uh so and a lot of people
might have heard the story but like the
tldr is like uh my my whole internet
Journey where they started on Tumblr
actually did audio posts those got
really like big the goofy covers right
some goofy covers posts and things like
that yeah that led to vine and then Vine
went really big and then Vine led to the
YouTube channel getting really big yeah
so it just those were the steps but that
was like
um 2012 uh I just graduated from college
right and I was like I don't know how
the [ __ ] I'm gonna do
um so I did made the Tumblr a voice
actor Tumblr did one post every day
every single day for like three four
years or whatever
eventually developed like a following
and then
that's what I uh attribute All My
Success to on in the online space is
that right and actually even the voice
acting space because I was practicing
voice acting right right
um prior to vine and even before people
knew who I was that's when I was
starting to look like independent like
video games and yeah you start getting
referred to other directors and stuff so
right
um
yeah a lot of people they even now to
this day they'll be like oh my God
prosody is in a game I'm like I have
been in like
a hundred things over the past like
eight years like I don't know but you
know but it's fine people some people
know you for one thing or yeah yeah yeah
um so that's that was where everything
it was just me sort of sitting down and
be like I want to do voice acting I
don't know how I'm going to get into the
industry yeah you just kind of make [ __ ]
on your own and you know yeah and that's
what the advice I always give to people
who are like how do you become a voice
actor it's like
just start making [ __ ] practice every
single day yeah
the classes make [ __ ] put yourself out
there meet other people and because like
a lot of people like you know including
you and like you know my age my age
that generation of voice actors All-Star
kind of started that way like you just
made stuff online whether it was fan
dubs or these things yeah [ __ ] posts
exactly and now you know we're ice ice
whenever I see people nowadays they're
like oh who's this newcomer I'm like no
I know who that is that guy's been like
you know yeah he's been grinding and
like you know yeah he's been working for
like years like he's not a newcomer at
all he's just like finally getting his
you know just like you know it is a
success that he deserves yeah you see
from like the old times you're like he's
killing it now yeah it's it's with me as
well because I even though I've never
been a voice actor or tried voice acting
uh I've always been aware of like I call
it like the vaa generation yes well it's
like there was this like voice acting
board called like the voice acting
Alliance where everyone would post find
and find like new fanned up projects or
bridging projects and I see a lot of
those names that I used to see on the
board now actually voicing like real
anime or just like [ __ ] killing it in
some other fields on YouTube or
something yeah it's obviously like
people are you know they're always going
to need new Talent yeah and who better
than the people who've been doing it
since they're like 15 online yeah a [ __ ]
yeah because in this one specialized
field yeah it's all just level grinding
right yeah it's level grinding and
grinding and then just getting to a
point where you're ready yeah
um pretty much yeah just trying to get
the the requirements you joke but
everything in my life is just like a
list of achievements
I want to play all these board games why
not eat all these restaurants like yeah
yeah well I find it funny because like I
remember back in the day there was
definitely like this air of just like
look look at these kids trying to get
into anime by doing fan dubs online [ __ ]
yeah no you got to go to like you you
got to be in the industry man these kids
are just playing around so it's actually
just gratifying just to see everyone
actually [ __ ] people actually
succeeding after putting in the grind
because it you know it might have been
like fan work and fan dubs but you get
like that's your experience yeah
um uh Sarah Jane Sherman who's a very
well-known casting director she recently
tweeted very similar like advice like
yeah just start making stuff like I've
seen people make tick tocks of them like
doing voices for their fish and it's
like I mean you laugh but it's like
that's actual you get you are
demonstrating yeah yeah ability right
you know it's a silly little thing like
that you know yes so I always encourage
people like yeah just make [ __ ] and see
what happens and just you know that's